against all predictions ecuadorians
celebrated a glorious Opening match of
the World Cup
[Applause]
odor's largest port city Guayaquil there
was special Pride many of the country's
top players are costenos which means
from Ecuador's Pacific Coast
making history we're celebrating
it's not just about kicking a football
Ecuador has a brain our players know how
to think and play that's going to take
us a long way
on this day a state of emergency
declared in the city because of
uncontrollable gang violence was
forgotten even the drug traffickers had
apparently declared a truce for the game
football is a passion in Ecuador the
king of sports but it's much more the
national team is one of the youngest
playing in the World Cup and is made up
almost entirely of black ecuadorians
from very poor neighborhoods
they're becoming role models for many
other young ecuadorians who are too
often tempted to resort to drug
trafficking and crime
it's only the beginning that Ecuador is
going to keep moving forward in this
world cup and that the world had
underestimated their team
the game has brought millions of
ecuadorians together behind one game and
one dream that they hope will take them
to the final of the World Cup
foreign